כן.
לא, כשמסתכלים על היכולות של היום אני חושב שזו
גם שאלה חשובה מאוד לשאול, בסדר
מה מפת הדרכים, כלומר כמה
יותר טובים המערכות האלה
וכמה יותר מורכבים
יהיו ה-circuit שנוכל להריץ
ובשביל זה פיתחנו מדד חשוב מאוד
שנקרא quantum volume
לפעמים אפשר לקרוא או לשמוע בעיתונות הפופולרית
את מספר ה-qubit וזה
וכמדד להתקדמות
אני אגיד ישר ש
סתם מספר ה-qubit במכונה הוא לא
מדד טוב להתקדמות
ההתקדמות צריכה להימדד לפי
רמת המורכבות של ה-circuit שאפשר להריץ
qubit והמכונות הטובות האלה לא מושלמות היום
ויש להם שגיאות שמוכנסות על ידי ההצמדה של
המערכת לעולם החיצוני
הכוח האמיתי של ה-qubit האלה
של ההסתבכות והתכונות האלה
הוא גם מה שהופך אותם גם לחזקים
וגם לרגישים להצטלבות
וחיבור לעולם החיצון
אז צריך להוריד את קצב השגיאות
בזמן שמגדילים את מספר ה-qubit
זה מה שמתואר פה
מה שבאמת רוצים לעשות זה לנוע באלכסון
ו-quantum volume הוא מדד שמשלב
את שני המדדים האלה ועוד כמה שיקולים מרכזיים נוספים